return my treasures to me and i myself
will carry you to the gates of valhalla
welcome to your weekly ticket
anya taylor joy is going to star in
george miller's upcoming mad max prequel
furiosa taylor joy has been cast in the
leading role that was originally played
by charlize theron in the oscar-winning
mad max fury road back in 2015. the film
will track the genesis of furiosa before
she teams up with max rockatansky and
fury road
chris hemsworth and yahya abdul mateen
ii will also star in the film but their
roles haven't been announced yet
miller will return to direct co-write
and produce the film
ridley scott and joaquin phoenix who
first collaborated all the way back 20
years ago on gladiator are teaming up
once again for a historical drama titled
kit bag phoenix will star as napoleon
bonaparte the french military leader who
ruled as emperor of the french
from 1804 to 1815. the film is said to
be a take on the story of napoleon's
ruthless and relentless ascent to the
top of french politics
and michael b jordan will produce a dc
movie titled static shock
the project was first revealed during
august dc fandom event and jordan will
produce via outlier society his
warner-based banner
the project focuses on static shock
which debuted in 1993 as a dc comics
distributed title from milestone comics
a comic banner created by black writers
and artists to help make comics a more
inclusive space
jordan said in a statement to the
hollywood reporter i'm proud to be a
part of building a new universe centered
around black superheroes
our community deserves that outlier
society is committed to bringing to life
diverse comic book content across
all platforms and we're excited to
partner with reggie and warner brothers
on this initial step
well we're gonna have to wait a little
longer for our next adventure with
hercule perot from death on the nile
but the good news is there's plenty of
murder mystery films to check out
and today we're looking at our favorite
murder mystery films of
all time and today to share his personal
recommendations from this list of
murder mystery films is film critic
robert daniels man robert how you doing
man
i'm great i'm fantastic actually right
now thanks for having me
absolutely so do you have a favorite
murder mystery from this list
yes i have uh one in particular the
mounties falcon
1941. most people don't know it's
actually an adaption off a
pulpy kind of short story and that
iteration was actually the third remake
for that film
so it was a kind of a story they've been
bouncing around it was kind of a b
movie in some ways humphrey bogart this
was kind of like the film that
really launched his career as humphrey
bogart before then he'd been playing
a lot of heels a lot of bad guys and
gangster films with cagney but this is
the one
him as detective sam spade hunting the
mile t stop and this
statue that everyone is hunting for that
is supposed to be
incredibly valuable that we later find
out is kind of a mcguffin
but it's one of the first times we see
the
teaming of bogart with cindy greenstreet
and peter laurie
that same team would reoccur and
casablanca for instance but everything
about this film is just it's fantastic
it's
absolute classic do you think we're due
for a remake
[Laughter]
i think i mean i think it's definitely a
film that could be remade like i said it
was this was the third remake
you know certainly yeah i mean i do
think it's it's such a simple story
why it succeeds especially based off
just a small object
like just a statue and the
romance that's happening between uh
bogart and his co-star
yeah i think we could we could
definitely do for a remake maybe
something that is diverse and
representative you heard it here first
robert daniels will be producing
a remake of the uh the maltese falcon
it's gonna be great can't wait
now death on the nile which is the
follow-up to the murder on the orient
express
is arriving soon there seems to be like
a trend of ensemble-based murder
mysteries
is there any that you recommend from
this list that people can watch right
now
yeah i mean i think a recent example is
probably knives out from ryan johnson
um very much is made in that agatha
christie
tradition it's also like columbo you
know you it begins
with you seeing the murder and then you
kind of have to work backwards
to what happened in the murder but it
also works obviously mr agatha christie
where daniel craig plays benoit blanc
who is kind of like this hercule parrot
kind of character that you'd see
you know and mystery mystery on the
orient express around the nile
yeah i mean it's a funny film it's a
film that is very aware
of the tropes of a murder mystery and
it plays into great effect many many
twists as well
yeah and also the sweater let's not
forget the sweater
i went out and bought i don't know a lot
of people bought that cable knit sweater
i
i bought one too i may have to wear it
for the second half of this uh
of this show for later on but um
but yeah that's it that's a great film i
i've i've never i haven't heard anybody
talk poorly on that
everyone loves that movie it's a great
yeah the sweater and then
daniel craig's donut inside the donut
and there's a spin off of that one too
so you're gonna see
this is watch watch me do this
transition you're gonna see that that
detective
in multiple uh movies which brings me to
my next question
many films on the list have detectives
with
multiple films what is your favorite
detective that starred in multiple films
oh that's a good question i guess you
know her coupon roll would be it you
know i've always been a fan of that
agatha christie character um and you
know death on denial and murder on the
orient express
are some of my favorite murder mystery
films and i mean it's one of those also
those characters that it's kind of like
you know james bond like so many people
have played them each person puts their
different spin on him
yeah i think that's my favorite awesome
all right well thank you robert for
coming on the show where can people find
you
yeah so people can find me on twitter at
eight one two film reviews
um my work can also be found on
consequence of sound rodribur.com the
playlist
ign and uh polygon nice
everywhere that's great all right well
thanks so much for coming on the show
robert
all right thank you very much for having
me all right
see i told you i'd swap into that
sweater available to watch in theaters
on friday
is the empty man
based on the 2014 graphic novel by the
same name the empty man tells the story
of a series of mysterious disappearances
in a small midwestern town
that may be linked to a supernatural
entity the film is written and directed
by david pryor and stars james badge
dale steven root and joel courtney
[Music]
and available to watch at home unhinged
you know what a courtesy tap is young
man sounds like this it's light
it's friendly sure that's what your mom
meant to do no it's not
mom rachel is a single mother whose bad
day gets even worse when she beeps her
horn at a fellow driver during rush hour
traffic
after an exchange of words she soon
realizes that the mysterious man is
following her
and her son in his truck the initial
case of road rage
quickly escalates into full-blown terror
as rachel discovers the psychopath
sinister plan for revenge alright well
that's it for today but check out that
full list of murder mystery films and
let us know which one is your favorite
by leaving a comment and also
if i pull this sweater off not like
chris evans pull off the sweater but
just like
in general i'm kale and i'll see you
next time
you